so what are you eating at first tell me  what you're eating I'm eating for lunch  Tomatoes tuna fish feta cheese and olive  oil now here's what's interesting about  you  you eat that every day every day every  day you eat the same thing yeah it's  well I it's it's very good you know I'm  sure it is otherwise we wouldn't eat it  every day right right so what do we eat  for dinner chicken little pieces of  chicken and broccoli and a little soy  sauce every day yeah every day except  when I travel then I go off that  is this can we say you're a creature of  habit yes Habit in a daily routine and  then when there's some sort of order  there then you're free to mentally go  off any any place you've got a safe sort  of foundation and and a place to Spring  off from and you view that in terms of  the creative process it's very important  it's very important for me for you yeah  the pure the environment the more you  know fantastic the interior world can be  it seems to me